you don't have to wear the mask i don't
have the rona bro
i took two tests i took two if i get him
and i leave here i got double negatives
i'm gonna have empire invoice you all
right all right speaking of empire so i
listen to the album and
don't body your work um do you feel like
this is like
uh like the coronavirus everything has
been going on i feel like you
it feels like you took a lot of time on
this project
like uh it felt real personal too
it is because of the title like it's
kind of like the sequel to fake love
and then real hate but um i feel like
the previous project hometown hero
before that was like that also
like i feel like you like like
vulnerable on this album i feel like i'm
on hometown heroes like that too i'm
just growing you know um
you know we growing every day and going
through different things so
i mean me as an artist i've been just
like giving you me
like what i'm going through how i'm
feeling so
it's just that and then another thing
too you know we grow as artists every
day as
we gain new fan base every day too so
maybe more people might be more
in been tuning in more lightly and just
probably just missed out on the past
stuff
um i i think it's dope that
independently what you've built over the
last 12 years
is very impressive i'm sure that there's
opportunities for you to
you know go the major label route plenty
of times
i'm curious they want uh they want
everything
of course they do yeah i i had a few
interviews whatever they was like they
wanted
whole catalogue and uh
merch and touring and all that you want
to cut of it all
everything i'm like well i didn't know
y'all in 2008 right
right right start from here on up right
like moving forward
yeah like we i can't do that i can't
take down what i already
built up and then give it to you and
then just so happened i didn't do it and
then corona hit
i would have been asked out so that was
something that was recently them
i mean it's been a few times but yet the
last one was right before
can you tell us who it was with rock
nation so roc nation was was
was trying to do business with filthy
rich and they yeah i had um
i had a meme set down on here and that
was something that
it looked like it would have been like
more of a 360 situation like they were
they were gonna want a piece of
everything you had going on
yeah including your old catalog
everything
yeah see that that doesn't make sense
like you said like it makes sense to me
from here forward yeah from me having an
independent
mindset like i'm seeing money off
digital you know and royalties and sound
exchange and
ass cap and youtube or whatever so it's
like okay i gotta give y'all all of this
i don't even know y'all
like i don't know what you about to do
for me or not going to do for me
you know what i'm saying so i'm taking a
chance as in believing in y'all
and hoping that y'all are going to do
something if y'all don't then i'm just i
don't pay you all already
yeah and then you're like you're you're
left with less than you had before
100 who now obviously you know everyone
associates rock nation with hove like
who was it that initially worked like
was it like do you know if like jay-z
was aware of
like your what you got going on or
because that you know they have their
own anrs and their own label people
and it was it was the rock nation
management
it wasn't uh the label side got you but
they was willing to bring me to a label
and um it was um i mean it's no like bad
blood or anything of course not
no i mean look people we you should
always take every meeting i'd say that
to everybody
um but his name is daniel okay actually
um celine's baby dad
oh that's what's up yeah man that's
crazy because it's salute to salute
daniel though for even just
believing in me want to sit down talk to
me like he came to my neighborhood like
he came to uh
i think uh a release party album release
party or
yeah i had going on he tapped in he
really came to the hood like they was
really trying to
yeah i had a video shoot out here and
inglewood he came through so he really
was rocking with me